start a pitcher for the cubs today
trevor williams
and he's going to attack these national
hitters with this assortment of
offerings for
seymour slider sinker curve and change
average fastball velocity
91.92 on the ground can they
turn it fires to nico on the first
and a double play i beg your pardon here
is josh bell now with two out of nobody
on
and that's a high fly ball to deep left
center c
u later josh bell fifth of the year
rbi number 16 and the nats are on top
after the walk in the double play
yeah josh bell had never faced trevor
williams because they wore the same
uniform in pittsburgh for five years
first a b against him takes him yard
schwarber's one for nine in the series
and swings and he skies one to left
field
toward the corner way back and gone
goodbye
jack peterson running out of room back
to back home runs
just a few pitches apart schwarber goes
yard to left on a 1-0 pitch from
williams
and bang zoom goes schwarber it's the
nationals two of the cubs nothing
alex avila left-handed batting catcher
swaying and a miss strike three and
avila
is gone but home runs by bell and
schwarber back to back
and there's joe ross six games five
starts against the cubs
trying to beat them for the first time
two-seam four-seam slider an occasional
change up for joe ross who needs to be
down today when he's gotten hit hard
over
his last couple starts ball has been
elevated 2-2 to peterson
and it looked like he got all locked up
maybe looking for something else
now he inhabits the switch hitting
center fielder and joe throws a quality
pitch on the outer edge
that's castro on the shift and that's it
for the cubs
andrew stevenson the center fielder
starting in place
of victor robles on the ground up the
middle over the mound
and baez makes the play and that is that
williams bounces back to get him one two
three so a single to start the second
nico horner at the plate and that one
ripped into right center field around
second he's not stopping stevenson up
with it
nico horner's been fun to watch huh
defensively
approach right and right center
cubs with a chance to get on the board
nick martini batting for the first time
today
the native of crystal lake in the air
out towards left center
stevenson makes the call in the grab
bodial tag from third
and it's a one-run game seven did his
job
well done nick martini there's trevor
williams
and he reaches out and makes some
contact on o2 unassisted by trey
to the bag but the cubs pick up a run on
two singles in a sec fly
here's juan soto soto hit into a double
play his first time
turner leads there he goes soto strikes
out throw to second base and
they got him strike him out throw him
out
double play perfect throw by higgins
baez made a quick tag
no challenge fourth coming from
washington and quickly
two down with nobody on jock peterson
leads off the bottom of the third for
the cubs
to the left-handed batter peterson and
joe ross goes up and away
second strikeout and peterson twice
that'll bring in anthony rizzo
ross delivers and a swing in a high
drive left field
this is deep schwarber back edge of the
track feeling for the ivy makes the
catch and then bangs into the ivy
that one almost caught the basket which
overhangs the ivy covered fence
but schwarber who knows that left field
corner as well as anybody was able to
make the play
as ian happ stands in 2-2
in the air curling down the right side
that one towards the corner
and it's gone he just got enough of
it it's a basketball his
second in the last few games into a
basket here at the ballpark the home run
is fifth and it comes on top
3-2 castro a single his first time beat
the shift
payoff pitch swing and a miss struck him
out
jordy mercer lifts one in the air
and half is there to pull it down
williams pitches around a two-out
walk the cubs lead it we're midway in
the fourth the cubs have a couple of men
on and let's see if that little single
turns out to be a key play with
john peterson coming up the one over
line drive base head peterson with the
knife
martini comes around it's 4-2 hard hit
ball
peterson gets the rbi the 1-1
oh chris conroy not looking david body
was trying to give him the heads up
that redirected either off i don't know
whether it hit the netting or the guy
wire
but chris conway just didn't expect
it to come at him and i think it hit him
in the belly
the nationals have men at first and
second here
in the top of the fifth josh bell due up
the pitch
check swing did he go yes he did struck
him out
justin steele comes in and puts out the
fire
ian gave the cubs the lead with a two
run shot in the third
in the air out towards left center field
stevenson back
on its way down
second of the day didn't need the basket
that time
[Applause]
well into the bleachers and half star to
hit his stride his fifth of the year
rebecca park is sixth of the year next
up is
nick martinez here's the pitch swung on
ground ball
sprawling to his right mercer field
straightens throws to first to bell
in time for the out two down here is
alex avila
outside corner how about that justin
steele out stand against him one two
three including a pair of strikeouts
and here it comes rizzo lines one
shallow center field that's a base hit
steel will stop at third he held up
momentarily
this loads the bags with one away base
is loaded for javi baez
up there hacking to the bag castro
engineers a 5-3 double play inning over
yadiel
hernandez pin shooting the 1-2
swaying and a miss overpowered
andrew stevenson left-handed batting
centerfielder and the one-two from
topera
swing and a miss strike three he strikes
out the side
it's time for the seventh inning stretch
josh bell
homered in the first has struck out
twice since
on the ground nicole horner dives gets
up
throws him out stop it nico suave
continues to play brilliant defense
on the right side of the infield nico
horner full extension
the moment of truth has arrived on this
thursday afternoon
top of inning number nine the cubs on
the brink of taking
three out of four craig kimbrell will
try to nail it down
and a one-two
cubs win kimbrough closes it out
and the cubs take three of four from the
next